on est toujours dans la rhétorique
d'intimidation c'est pas nouveau ces
propos exagérés injustifiée qui ne
correspondent pas du tout à la réalité
mais c'est une logique de rhétorique
agressive escale à thouars qu'on connaît
depuis le début du conflit visa quoi
c'est qui vise à nous intimider à nous
dissuader je me rappelle que lorsque le
président poutine et le président mac
ronfleur conférence de presse avant même
le début du conflit vous savez dans cet
épisode de moscou le président poutine
lui même avait tenu des discours
alarmistes de cette manière c'est de
l'intimidation laquelle il faut pas
céder